Welcome to the mini-unit. It's really about how to learn new things
When you're trying to develop as a programmer as well as trying to understand how to solve
new problems. In CS101, I tried to keep things as simple as possible,
using only a very small subset of Python. The reason for this
was to focus on learning new concepts in Computer Science
rather than learning lots and lots of different Python constructs.
And I think that is the right way to begin as a computer scientist. You should learn
to construct programs using only a few simple things that you understand well,
focusing on the problems to solve, the algorithms to solve them
and understanding how things work, rather than learning lots
of new language constructs. But if you want to become a better programmer,
well then, you need to start learning more of the language. And most of our courses
don't focus on that. They focus on concepts important for problem-solving,
understanding what's going on in a computation and analyzing
and reasoning about them. But to become a better programmer, you also need to learn more
of the language. And the main goal of this unit is to help
you learn how to actually learn things on your own. Becoming a better
programmer really depends on two things - it depends on experience:
and you get experience by solving more and more problems; and it depends on
knowledge. And you gain knowledge also by solving problems, but
it's a different kind of thing. Knowledge means learning more language constructs,
learning more algorithms, knowing more different ways of solving problems.
That's different from the experience you get by solving a lot of problems yourself.
And both of those are important for becoming a better programmer.